so i i see you started genting oh yeah
yeah
after holding off this entire [ __ ]
time and holding
the crew and holding off from like me
and joey talking about it like
if every every week didn't want a
[ __ ] sponsor
our [ __ ] podcast to become a sponsor
episode
for free if we're going to talk about
genshin i want to get [ __ ] paid
you know what i mean
do you like it though it's fine if it
feels like breath of the wild light
you know what i mean like yeah yeah it
feels like it's diet breath of the wild
you know how i can breath the wild when
you would like think oh what if i do
this like weird thing
and then you'd always get rewarded for
it yeah and gentian i would do that and
i'd be like
oh there's nothing there really it's
another common chest oh
boy don't understand what i'm picking up
because because the reason i like
genshin and i've
the reason i like it is that it is very
very breath of the wild oh yeah that's
the best part of the game yeah yeah but
it's it's breath of the wild mixed with
basically jrpg elements
i'm just like [ __ ] awful i was
watching this guy's stream
yeah every time pymon came on screen he
was like shut up
there was like there's one point where
was a cut scene i think like i just
like had my mouse to my head and i was
just tapping it yeah
because i was so bored the story's so
[ __ ] not that i would have paid
attention anyway yeah
but it's like doubly [ __ ] and then some
people in my chat were like why are you
skipping the [ __ ] cut scenes and i'm
like it's [ __ ] right and everyone's like
yeah it's kind of [ __ ]
and i was like okay good then i'm
skipping them all yeah yeah yeah i don't
know that's like
it's boring i i don't find any of these
characters interesting i just yeah
because they're all gatcha characters
and most of them are
just i don't know i mean like the thing
with gacha game stories is that they
rarely start off goods you know it's if
if a gotcha story gets good it's
normally like
way into development where like five
chapters in or like five
like when when they release like their
fifth story um
like chapter six arc yeah yeah yeah
which i've heard about chapter six arc
nights which is meant to be amazing and
i'm just like
well i've kind of skipped the entire
story up to this point so i just don't
trust anyone
i've read chapter one and that's it
after that i was like oh okay
i don't need to know the story to play
the game yeah i just don't understand
people who like love stories in gacha
games i just i mean we've covered this
before but yeah have we
i mean video games yeah but i mean
they're especially [ __ ] in gotcha
yeah like breath of the wild like didn't
have much story and that's like the best
part of the game
yeah but like the reason why people
skipped over [ __ ] breath of the wild
story is because like
what person who doesn't know the story
what is this what is the story of breath
of the wild the gallon like
yeah you just just began it right that's
nice though i like that they kept it
simple like let me do it
i mean i like the fact that you can
change characters and is elemental and
the combat's
kind of fun it's okay it feels pretty
limited but yeah i mean it's fine i mean
i mean
the reason i thought it was great was
because it feels like gentian's like
kind of kind of feels like a first of
its kind right because
when you think of gacha games and when
you think of like you know the whole the
whole gacha genre
you you have this uh you have this image
of just like you know
cheap mobile games that only hardcore
weebs are into yeah and it's been really
[ __ ] weird seeing just how much
genshin has blown up
and i feel like i went into genshin
thinking
oh it's just gonna be kind of like
honkai but a little bit more polish
and i got completely blown away when i
was just like no this just feels like
a triple a gacha game it feels like the
very very first triple a gacha game
where it's like
way more polished than pretty much any
of its competition
like i didn't understand why people
liked fake go like i saw fake go
it looked it's it's because of fate but
it looked like a [ __ ] mini clip game
the art looked [ __ ] and then also the
story sounded like a convoluted mess
and then also the gaucher rates were
abysmal so whatever it does because you
don't miss it's like
type move fans like kpop fans right it's
like the moment there's anything type
moon they just
like give it to me so so so there's this
thing called like the waifu economy
right
where it's it's it's the value of the
waifus and because
because type moon have such like
like because ty moon have such a strong
brand with fate and all the wife who's
in it
that just makes the waifus and fate
worth that much more and people
like you you look like you're about to
die inside right now
does actually get good like [ __ ] five
chapters in i can't remember
which chapter camelot is but that's what
that's that's when it gets good
so when you're playing the gadget games
do you want the characters because you
like them or because they'll make you op
um i mean i'm sure it goes both ways
that's that's that's the
eternal struggle right do you go with
meta
or do you go with waifus i just want the
op ones i don't care about the
character's looks
oh i'm completely the opposite because
like every time i stream genjin
there are so many [ __ ] backseaters
for games there are two types of people
in this world
there are so many [ __ ] backseaters
for genshin where like i think once i
had like
both chichi and clee in like my party
and people like what the [ __ ] that's
like the worst combination i'm like i
don't give a [ __ ]
i like these characters i just want to
play as the characters i like i like
these waifus i i honestly think
like going with the just the wife the
good wife is the way to go because
i feel like going into a gacha game
wanting to be op
means that you kind of go into the
mentality where you want to like kind of
complete the game it's like
right it's like going into a casino
expecting to be a millionaire no
no you want to complete the game wait
are we not completing the game is that
all we're all doing am i confused
no i mean if you want to don't want to
complete the game no no no no
no it's not how can you complete a gacha
game do the story
but the story isn't everything in a
gotcha game yeah yeah okay so you do the
story in genji all right and then what
then what'd you do
you go around exploring the world or you
collect all the characters or
collect all the cat you ain't gamble all
your [ __ ] money away yes welcome to
gotchas connor
i've never [ __ ] bought once you've
done all the content
in the game right what do you do then
he's like wait for the next update
but like okay that's where like when uh
arc nights came out right
the weight between those things was just
like a ticking time
bomb of like am i gonna drop this game
right like because that wait period is
like how long can i reasonably like keep
logging into this like yeah right
to the point where i'm like what am i
doing yeah and obviously like after x
amount of time when you've beaten the
game
that's when it's like okay i'm done like
i'm i've played this game i've got my
fill i don't need to spend any more
money on this
i find it really funny though that
you're the one who's like no i want to
finish the story
as someone who has no idea what the [ __ ]
this story is about i want to do all
like the content all the bosses like
all the fun normally unfortunately it's
tied to the story
because i i remember but unfortunately
all the boss fights are tied to a story
it's like seeing seeing you enter like
discover arc nights for the first time
and seeing you like your first
entrance into the world of gotcha i'm
just like i see him
i just saw you spiraling down into hell
because i thought you were like
oh man i want to collect this i want to
level up this character when i level up
that character i want to optimize this
and i'm like
oh no you're going to be spending a lot
of money well that was because like i
wanted to
unfortunately with arc knights it would
always be that one stage arc nice it's
like a tower defense kind of game
yeah um uh please sponsor us
and uh basically there was always no
matter how many op characters you had
there'd always come a stage where you
needed like one specific character that
had this one niche that you didn't have
yeah it was super annoying when it
happened so i just wanted to spec
everything and uh to be prepared for
every stage
and then uh yeah i just gave off yeah
which which is which is what i was
saying like if you want to complete a
catch
like complete i got your game you're
going to have a bad time because i felt
like i completed dark nights
like i did everything i mean there's
there's always new content coming out
like you you never know there is now
the only time you can complete a gacha
game is when the developers just stopped
yeah this is the thing right if when you
have done everything in a game right
yeah say the next patch coming out in a
month
yeah like are you then happy to stop
playing that game before the new
chapters come out next month
which is which is done which is why like
which is why i feel like this is a super
interesting conversation because i feel
like
a lot of people went into genshin and
they like i don't think gentian eve
i don't think even genshin kind of
expected the kind of
like response that he would have gotten
and how popular would have gotten
because
this is like a lot of people's first
introduction
into gacha games right and there's been
like a big controversy with genshin
stamina system
uh when you reach endgame right when
when you kind of complete the story
explore everything so stamina is for
running around swimming and climbing
right
no no no no so you haven't used stamina
and against you i haven't oh okay no no
so you
you understand okay so every gacha game
has kind of like a stamina system where
normally
you spend a resource to play some
certain aspects of the game right
genshin to me i feel like it's it's it's
super weird right because you can go
you could play it for like 30 like 30
plus hours
and never have to use the stamina system
at all whereas
whereas with like arc nights has sanity
you kind of like you kind of like
you kind of like reach the stamina cap
within like a week of playing it all out
i'd say right
same thing with like fake go i can't
remember what the stamina system
system in fake go is called but in
genshin the stamina system is called
resin
and you use resin whenever you like go
complete a dungeon or don't go like
flights and bosses
now when you're in the early game and
when you're just exploring the world
you can just not use the stamina system
at all because there's
so much to do and the world is like the
world's [ __ ] massive yeah right
the world's absolutely massive um that
you could
spend 30 plus hours exploring the world
doing everything in the world doing
story quests and not have to like
focus on grinding and leveling up your
characters and doing bosses and
everything but
once you've reached the end game once
you explored everything then there is
nothing to do
but grind it out and you know and um
and try to try to yeah and just use
resin and
the argument is from what i understand
because i haven't actually reached
endgame myself is that
there is just not enough resin to like
give you
meaningful content once you've reached
the end of the content
i mean i i don't understand people who
like
just grind like we'll play a game for
hours on end and grind when there's no
guarantee that anything's coming
yeah like that that's like psychotic to
me yeah because i've heard that
the best way to like enjoy genjin from
from what i've heard from people who
have reached endgame already is that
you shouldn't rush through the game no
you shouldn't because getting to endgame
is actually
much quicker than a lot of people expect
and once you hit that point
and once you have to start using the
stamina system then it's like you're
really limited to what you can do yeah
you're really limited to content and
that and that's why i think it genshin's
like this super unique
um super unique uh example because most
gacha games
it's it's just like a mobile game where
you just like you play you can play it
for like five to ten minutes so pop
sometimes you know you've already played
for long periods of time
whereas with genshin because it feels
more like a aaa game people want to play
this for hours on end
and people are coming in expecting this
to be like an mmo rpg
where you're just like constantly
grinding and constantly doing something
and this is like
infinite content right i just find
mmorpgs so boring
after like x level right when you start
grinding yeah yeah
i i don't know like i think some people
can do grinding no problem but for me
it's like
well i mean you hate jrpgs yeah i mean i
i just like
i think it's like why would you just
stop me from having fun
like i don't understand some people find
grinding really fun
yeah i think it's like relaxing for some
people i find it relaxing for me it's
just like i feel like you're just like
taking the piss out of me like you're
just kind of making a mockery of my time
here like that you're making me do
you're only making me use one percent of
my brain almost it's like you know
some when i used to play runescape like
i didn't mind it but i was also
[ __ ] 12 and i was a dumb little [ __ ]
and i wouldn't mind oh were you
i literally spent like hours a day
clicking trees i can't even believe i
did that
but were you playing like mmos by
yourself or were you playing with
friends i had friends as well
okay but still but like i mean i
couldn't be able to
grind like an mmo by myself like raids
look fun in world of warcraft
like when it's like eight people
communicating like that looks fun but i
also
don't want to get there because the
points are getting there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and my little
brother was addicted to world of
warcraft and he [ __ ]
he couldn't get him off i never got into
world of warcraft i've never been into
i don't think i've played like a single
mmorpg
um because i like not even runescape i
didn't even play runescape
runescape i just spent so many hours on
that game
yeah i just like begged my parents when
i was like 14 like please mother
please pay for membership it's only five
pounds a month
i didn't have the balls to ask my
parents to do that so that's why i was
like no
i think it was like for my birthday i
was like can i have runescape
for a year and they were like yeah and
obviously when you were like 14 time
doesn't go nearly as fast as it does now
right
right yeah so i remember like the first
month i played like eight hours a day of
runescape every day i was so addicted
true gaming goal right here yeah yeah
and when i got like 17 i stopped playing
and i gave my account to my little
brother because he wanted to play on it
for a little bit
yeah like [ __ ] lost all my [ __ ]
i i remember there was like this thing
called like uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] there was this thing you had to
grind for like the specific armor and it
took me like months and he lost it
like mithril armor or some [ __ ] i was
like was it like called fist of gothics
or something i don't know what
it was like this armor where you had to
play this like egg game it was really
dumb i spent like
like i would spend like two weeks
straight getting this armor doing these
[ __ ] mini games and then he lost it
and then i got it
again i came out of retirement from
runescape
just to get him retired i came out of
runescape retirement just to get this
armor again and he [ __ ] lost it again
and i was like that's it i'm done with
runescape
i'm quitting i pulled like a hayao
miyazaki right yeah i'm coming out
to save this company i couldn't believe
it